[Music]
come on
foreign
[Music]
as everyone knows that we have small
Masjid and we're trying to raise the
money because alhamdulillah we have a
lot of people attending the Masjid
especially for our classes and jummah so
we need a bigger place so last time we
did record small video showing the the
situation of our place and the alleyway
and the problem that we have of course
our Masjid is a private rent so we
cannot control what has happened outside
and the last time you saw there's many
rubbish outside blocking the people's
path and we open the madrasa many
families got scared to bring their
children is the message because of the
early way of it was smoking drugs and
alhamdulillah we have this place because
this place
Arabic language these people
many books
the dean of Allah
because last time we did not record
everything so we're going to show you
the entrance into the Masjid to know the
situation all right
I hope you're all doing well and for
those that are wondering they've been
asking for some time what does our
Masjid look like this is the pathway to
our Masjid as you can see this is the
pathway from literally there all the way
up to there the situation clearly is in
dire need this is the rubber we have to
walk through and today funny enough the
situation isn't even that bad but if you
think this is bad it's been worse we've
got boxes we've got garbage we've got
rats at time we've got sometimes people
just laying around sleeping you know
what I mean so unfortunately the
situation isn't the best
regardless of what it is we have a
Masjid but for those that are wondering
this is the reality of the Masjid we've
got Rubble all by debris you know so
don't think that the situation that
we're in right now is the best situation
it's not exactly plausible but uh you
know this is why we're asking you know
the people after last pantala first and
foremost to donate generously and
immensely because we are in need of
donations so we're going to walk you
through the clinic that we go through
every day and as you can see the path is
uneven so it's clearly a healthy a
health and safety uh issue even though
that's an issue with the brothers like
the little disabled Brothers on a
wheelchair they try to come by they
cannot come due to the the pathways
Behind the Lights very hard for people
to come you know even old people but
alhamdulillah we have a measure that
history
it's been around for nearly nine years
and they're teaching the people the
Arabic language
outside in our area outside Trevor Bush
Central Line station alhamdulillah so my
brothers and sisters course after Allah
we are asking people to donate in order
for us to have a new place because we
had madrasa but due to the place again
sometimes like the proper mentioned to
be honest if you think this is bad you
haven't seen it sometimes it's worse but
you have people here smoking drugs but
it had to be left so some families were
not happy to bring their children here
and we do understand that you know so of
course what we have to do we had to rent
another place just to have a madrasa for
the children for the girls and the boys
to teach our Muslim children the the
dean of Allah in our time when there's a
lot of tries and tribulations a lot of
people try to not to weigh our children
from us we had to be left we have to
teach the children of income so if you
can help you do your best Mala bless you
all and then of course we try to get a
place around the area you know uh Allah
foreign
so it's kind of 11 years then so more
what kind of activities have you guys
been providing at this uh alhamdulillah
we have a class Arabic classes and
classes we have classes we have Akita
classes and by the way all of them is
free we don't charge and we have madrasa
for the boys and the ghosts but like I
mentioned before due to the place some
families gets worried bringing their
children here especially when we had the
mothers in the evening so we had to look
for another place subhanallah so yes we
have many we have sisters classes for a
Sunday so alhamdulillah we have uh we
have activities alhamdulillah even we
have we have our research we have Albert
Ahmed Allah who does the footballs
football with the young boys
speak about it as well so
challenges you've been facing in this
what's the main challenge is there God
one of the main challenges is after
Maghrib you know when the Sun goes down
the issue at hand is it's very dark
there's no lighting you can't really
bring your families here it's not safe
and it's not exactly too inviting so
imagine walking through this telecast
night being pitch black and on top of it
you've got people smoking got people
drinking and on top of that it's not
exactly too inviting so our main point
is it's not suitable for families it's
not even suitable for some you know
males to come here let alone females
many brothers the first time some
brothers they came here therefore it was
a setup yeah one brother told me
actually literally I was uh he was on
the main road and he was asking where is
the Masjid so the prophet said let me
show you he said when he brought me he
said he tried to set me up
so my dear brothers and my sister mother
bless you all of course
Allah's sake Allah Buddha Palace for him
in Paradise Island we need your help
after the help of Allah
alhamdulillah Allah and we asked us to
have another place which we can which
allow us to have more people
foreign
[Music]